les choses révélé des filles on card à
mykonos des défis
d'ailleurs le plus gros défi que vous
êtes lancés y apparaît en bout vous
c'était d'être cocu plus d'une fois
c'est quoi le plus gros des fastes et
conquérir château et la gare lagarde
c'est fait pour conquérir sa tout c'est
vrai j'ai tourné tant de fois autour
d'elle qu'à un moment elle a cédé c'est
à dire que j'en ai fait une sorte
d'obsession névrotique à l'oreille mais
qu'est ce que tu veux et donc du coup
elle a fini par comprendre qu'il y avait
quelque chose de possible s'angoisse or
vous n'avez pas l'air de croire c'est
lui qu'il faut venir chercher c'est la
police merci vous quand vous est fait
pour séduire rouge et vous avez parlé
fort
d'accord il avait bossé dur lui ai parlé
fort parce que c'était en discutons
boîte de nuit attendais pas c'est vrai
qu'il est patron de l'esam ça c'est vrai
et donc après la première fois que je l'
ai vu quelques jours après deux jours
dans un restaurant et je pouvais
entendre sa voix le voir sans les spots
ça m'a fait tout bizarre tu sais rien
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un d'autre au
final la nuit les gens sont là tous les
chats sont gris
je tiens vous comment vous avez c'est
lui vaut de nombreuses femmes bon alors
on est à l'heure actuelle parce que tu
as les services avant à merde
mais
raconter pas c'était sur le plateau
ouais je sais plateau mais en fait je
les invités après à des jeunes et moi
j'étais marié l'époque et elle est allée
manger dans un restaurant japonais et
entre deux sushi j'ai donné des maux
j'ai un problème je crois bien que je
exact exacte
et sans déconner mais j'ai jamais
ce qu'elle avait rien dedans surtout la
drogue et oui ça quand même arriver ce
rigoler mais il venait quand vous êtes
morts de faim moi j'ai des copains après
le ramadan après et qui pourrait bien
moi je n'importe quoi bah moi c'est
pareil mais c'est pareil mais voilà
flamand ça a fonctionné ça à foot c'est
vous feriez pas loin en séries mais elle
reprendra de sushis 1 le coin cuisine
très bien que j'ai un problème je crois
mais c'est horrible mais comment faites
vous alors moi je
le sais il me connaît
c'est lui je laisse génial et si je vois
que lui nierait ch e comment se
manifeste je ferme ma porte commence à
se former est une femme pour une brèche
une femme qui a une santé canada
si c'est le cas vous prenez l'initiative
avait jamais j'apprends jamais vraiment
c'est vraiment il me connaît dit la
vérité
comme il ne saurait lui bah oui c'est ça
le connaît moi je n'ai jamais vu oui
enfin que
non mais c'est tout enfin voudra tout
faire revoilà guillaume on connait ouais
ouais ouais je serai prêt passif
franchement c'est pas
exagérer quand même risque elle vous
envoie des signaux pas exact vous dire
tu peux y aller moi gens pressés boutoir
exactement je dirais quand même un des
signaux
exactement votre force c'est que vous ne
drague et pas voilà cher et quand on
drague pas des gens en viennent à vous
ah ouais on en parle tout à l'heure mais
j'ai eu le sentiment hier oui et qui
s'est passé alors c'est peut être moi
avons été nombreux sur twitter qui s'est
passé quelque chose
avec marine le pen
en tous les cas qu'elle vous a trouvé
séduisant hassan elle a envoyé des cv
décidé au bris ces signaux la être en
contact avec d'autres
oui mais pas à 10 heures ça il n'y a pas
que moi j'ai beau regarder si les
professionnels